the ACLJ Judicial Watch have equally on
their own unearth some of the most
damning evidence exposing a two-tiered
justice system in terms of obtaining the
Obama DOJ immunity agreements with
Hillary Clinton's attorneys her lawyers
Cheryl Mills and Heather Samuelson to
dispose of evidence and refuse to comply
with federal law now trust me Donald
Trump would never receive this kind of
special treatment we have a full report
tonight but first we begin Democrats the
media mob they have once again they have
teamed up to accuse the president of
storm rates no Russia right no racism I
forget which day of the week it is it's
always something
all because he dared to speak the truth
and we've got all the facts and evidence
will lay out about what is human
suffering a tragedy not just in the city
of Baltimore but in pretty much every
liberal city across this country now for
months we have been chronically on the
show what is the utterly preventable
unnecessary human crisis disaster in the
most liberal cities in America as the
left attacks detainment centers for
illegal immigrants by the way Griff
Jenkins last week he took a tour of one
of their larger facilities you know the
ones that liberals have been comparing
to Nazi concentration camps now by the
way there's food there's water there's
medicine there's beds blankets pillows
medical attention baby formula diapers
soccer fields other recreational
activities TVs phones all courtesy of
you the taxpayer not ideal but they
didn't respect our laws and sovereignty
and they are here illegally but they're
definitely trying now meanwhile a much
different story for example in the city
of Baltimore over the weekend the
president called out 13 term congressman
Elijah Cummings for failing to address
what are the dire problems right there
in his district which is experiencing
record violence poverty far worse than
the facility Grif Jenkins went to and
corruption on a nearly unimaginable
scale we to here the amount of money I'm
going to tell you about a minute now
naturally instead of focusing on the
deteriorating living conditions in
Baltimore Democrats and now vigorously
there
just defending Cummings with another
round of identity politics feign false
selective moral outrage and of course
attacking the president calling him a
racist as many times they can every
second every minute every hour of every
day because the Muller thing fell apart
for them he called Baltimore dangerous
he said it was rat infested let's see
just last year the mayor of Baltimore
then mayor Katherine poon literally said
she could smell the rats when walking
through a neighborhood in her own city
she said it watch about a year ago city
leaders identified some of the city's
most violent neighborhoods
what the hell we should just take always
to target who use of smaller grants
under Baltimore's violence reduction
initiative Baltimore's violence
reduction initiative is about taking
steps to rid communities of the
cornerstones that contribute to crime oh
my god you can smell the dead animals
Mike it's smelling did the mayor of
Baltimore said that in case you were
wondering no outrage from Democrats over
those comments also no outrage when
senator Bernie Sanders compared
Baltimore to a third world country oh if
you're a liberal you can say it if
you're a liberal accused of sexual
assault like a lieutenant governor of
the Commonwealth of Virginia or if you
accused a rape there's no I believers
it's only if you're with Trump only if
you're a conservative only if you're
appointed by Trump just like Oh
obstruction of justice Hillary can do
whatever she wants
Trump has no obstruction but will say he
does anyway take a look but the fact of
the matter is is that America is the
wealthiest country in the history of the
world but anyone who took the walk that
we talked we took around this
neighborhood would not think you're in a
wealthy nation you would think that you
were in a third world country a
community that does not even have decent
quality grocery stores where moms can
buy quality food for their kids a
community in which the dream of getting
a higher education for many kids is as
real as is going to
the moon Bernie Sanders called Baltimore
while a third world nation since then
the conditions in Baltimore frankly they
have gotten dramatically worse it is a
crisis the city's trash mismanagement
their rodent infestation has become so
bad a recent documentary entitled rat
film highlighted the local government's
massive urban planning failures vacant
buildings line many streets in the West
in these parts of Baltimore all told
there are nearly 17,000 abandoned
structures in city limits the city's
educational system let's look at the
records it also is in a state of rules
look at the last year for which we have
data 2017
well investigation zero pay attention
zero students in five Baltimore high
schools and one middle school were
proficient in math in English there was
it one student proficient you've got to
be kidding at total by the way whopping
13 high school students had zero
students proficient in math and just
like Nancy Pelosi needs to focus on
let's see the needles all over the
streets people urinating defecating in
the streets the feces in the streets in
her home districts all looks like the
representatives from that are elected
from Baltimore need to focus on their
disintegrating districts right before
your eyes it's open your eyes
Baltimore's unemployment rate is the
third highest of any major city in
America the poverty rate in Baltimore a
whopping 22 percent household median
income is $11,000 less than the national
average but the most dire issue in
Baltimore is its violent crime look at
this 2017 Baltimore named the most
dangerous big city in America that year
more people murdered in Baltimore than
ever before now if you look at it at a
per capita basis there were more than
twice as many shootings in Baltimore
than in Chicago yeah that's ACOG oh and
in 2018 the city's murder rate was
higher than in any in the then higher
than in the country of Honduras what
that's where citizens are fleeing to see
Kasai
at the US border and this year
Baltimore's murder rate is on the rise
again through the first half of 2019 a
16 percent increase in murders 28
percent increase in non-fatal shootings
it's no surprise that Baltimore seeing a
huge decrease of population as a mass
exodus going on and I can't blame people
for this losing nearly 300,000 people in
just a couple of decades including a 20
percent 20,000 drop a thousand drop
since 2010 New York Times even the New
York Times calling it the tragedy of
Baltimore
now who can blame people for leaving
just like they're leaving in droves as a
mass exodus out of these highly
regulated high tax states like this one
then I'm stuck in because work makes me
stay here New York or New Jersey or
California or Illinois and without a
doubt we are now witnessing a human
crisis we've got to do better the people
in those detention centers that broke
the law didn't respect our borders our
sovereignty they are living better than
the people of Baltimore and other big
liberal cities how is that possible but
they're calling those concentration
camps and comparing those to Nazi
Germany and the Democratic leadership in
Baltimore they have failed their
citizens for decades liberal democratic
policies have failed the people of
Baltimore just like the people in San
Francisco just like the people in Los
Angeles New York City especially under
comrade de Blasio and elsewhere
congressman Elijah Cummings seems like a
nice guy
he's been in Washington for 23 years all
while his district is becoming worse and
worse and worse but of course he's
lashing out at the President and of
course Baltimore is just one of many
major cities run by liberalism
experiencing these serious problems
which is why on this program we have
investigated multiple cities which are
deteriorating right before our eyes
violent crime homelessness drug
addiction poverty violence wreaking
havoc in metropolitan areas all across
America all while Democrats and those
big city governments are unwilling or
unable to address these very real
problems by the way if you're gonna
leave New York fine you're gonna go to
the Carolinas if you're going to go to
Florida fine don't bring your idiotic
liberal policies with you if you're
leaving the great state of California
and moving to a state like Texas don't
do to Texas what you did to California
what you are now trying to get away from
and San Francisco one of the most
liberal cities in America now imagine
this one mile from Nancy Pelosi's gated
community home one mile in the other
direction to our office the homeless
problem they are spiraling out of
control needles all over the streets
public defecation
you're a nation and much worse la we've
gone to LA like we went to San Francisco
experiencing similar problems
yet the Democratic legislators there
have failed to address these very real
issues which have very real consequences
for everybody living in these
communities so tonight as many in the
media mob they're just busy lashing out
at President Trump he told the truth the
evidence is overwhelming it's
incontrovertible the statistics are
there if you really care about people
all you people on the Left if you care
about people how about you fix these
cities because that's our national
treasure our kids are dying violence out
of control drugs out of control and
poverty everywhere